[Music]
good evening welcome to Washington I'm
Bret bear it now seems to be a matter of
when not if President Trump will
authorize the release of a currently
classified memo about alleged
surveillance abuses by the FBI exactly
which version of the document will be
revealed is also a subject of heated
argument tonight chief intelligence
correspondent Catherine Herridge begins
our coverage by telling us where we
stand at this hour and we have to say at
this hour because it's been changing it
has been Brett thank you after another
day of brutal recriminations and a call
for the Republican House Intelligence
Committee Chairman to be removed the
White House signaled the memos release
is imminent we're concerned about
national security and transparency we
want the public to understand and know
what's going on the White House said the
memo is undergoing a final national
security check and the president sign
off it's gonna get review from all
relevant stakeholders that includes
intelligence folks and folks in law
enforcement community they'll be
advising the president and he'll make a
decision at the appropriate time
traveling bad from the GOP retreat in
West Virginia a senior White House
officials said they will tell Congress
promptly Friday that the president is
quote okay with it and redactions are
unlikely at the same retreat the Speaker
of the House defended the process and
his chairman of the House Intelligence
Committee whose staff authored the memo
I think they would love nothing more
than to play politics and change the
subject
Devon nudists helped Shepherd through a
reauthorization of 702 which is the
foreign terrorist foreign surveillance
law so he's focusing on keeping our
country safe focus on national security
I think what they're trying to do is his
side track us with some political game
Democrats who drafted their own version
came out swinging against newness the
ultimate decision would be made by the
president when the president reads the
Democratic memo and it shows that the
the Republican memo is just flat-out
false my guess is that he doesn't
authorize its release the House Minority
Leader Nancy Pelosi went further calling
for the Chairman's removal the Senate
Minority Leader Chuck Schumer said the
California congressman will stop at
nothing to undermine the Russia probe
attack our law enforcement as well as
intelligence officials and mislead his
house colleagues the house committee's
ranking Democrat Adam Schiff accused
Republicans of secretly making material
changes that under long-standing
congressional rules disqualified the
memos release she
said the real goal was undermining the
separate special counsel Russia probe
because of serious and material
omissions is inaccurate and gives a very
misleading impression designed to tar
the FBI and part R of the Department of
Justice a government source disputed the
characterization describing the edits as
minor including grammar at least two
changes were made at the request of the
FBI and Democrats with the memos release
appearing to be a certainty committee
Republicans tried to tamp down
expectations I think Republicans
sometimes make the mistake of over
selling things but I'm saying this is
vital it's essential for the public to
see and it's certainly important in the
body of evidence to be out there the
FBI's rare public statement morning of
the memos accuracy puts director Rea at
odds with the White House and
congressional Republicans though getting
into the memo today the FBI agents
Association released a statement
thanking director ray for standing
shoulders just soldiered with agents who
put the country's security first breath
Kevin what are we learning about the
special council's focus on that Trump
Tower meeting and what he wants to get
out of that
well after media reports that the
special counsel is focused on White
House communications director ho pix
after allegations she said emails about
the 2016 meeting would never get out
the lawyer Vegas released this statement
as most reporters know it's not my
practice to comment in respond to
questions from the media but this
warrants a response she never said that
in the idea that ho pix ever suggested
that emails or other documents would be
concealed or destroyed is completely
false press ok Catherine thank you